in this capsule we will see
the local search algorithm closed
then the climbing algorithm is
probably the simplest sentry box
local search to run
the algorithm we must specify a node
initial one must obviously also
specify the objectives function we
wish to optimize i want the tf of
hate in the slides and we have to
also determine for the hand
what are his naked successor we're going
sometimes called our neighbors so we can
do that by specifying a function that
we return the list of naked
successor given a current node
n is the method will run as
therefore follows the notion of a current one
which will be updated as and when
measurement as we execute the algorithm is this
we go there we will initiate it read
initial unu that was given as input to
the algorithm is then from her to a
iteration to the other the current node is going
be updated the following way one
will actually compare it to the nude
successor in order to see if we can not
transfer a new node 1 our
neighbors our successors who is a
best for the function of by the
objective function so among other things if
there is a neighbor a premium who has the
better value of hate and who in
more has a prime f2m value which is more
great that fdn so the discussion
guess we're maximizing
our objective function otherwise we
would not have smaller ones are minimized the
goal function
so if we find a new neighbor a
premium that has the best value f2m
premium among all the neighbors and who
improves in addition to the
objective function for the nuc current n
we will sign the current node at this
new zero at a premium
otherwise if there is not a neighbor who
improves the function
the value of the objective function we are going
stop running the algorithm and
we will return the current name
here is a description hope solo cote de
the algorithm we will give as input
united sial said two hours the name
current then to our neighbors a bonus that
is considered initializes our null
initial we assign the crown nose
initial being so long that we have not
a condition of arriving we will identify
the 2nd bonus that the successor
the highest value of f2m prime so
water here we have a variant that maximizes
otherwise we would rather be minimized this
would be the smallest value the most
small values
now if our potential neighbor in
premium had a value that is more
small or equal to the objective function
evaluate to n
it would mean that we will not have succeeded
to improve in relation to our function
goal in that if we would return
the current then if not we have one thing
of neighboring current between and on
continue like this until
eventually we enter this
part of the algorithm and we go back
the name runs so more
intuitive
we can see the execution of this
northern algorithm as someone who gets
moves in a kind of valley or
lands or f2m would correspond to
the elevation of the land and our goal
if they have maximized this function there this
would find a summit in the
hill that we are exploring and
but now imagine that we are
in a region there are a lot of
fog and we only see
hours no distance and well the
elkaim bing method correspond to a
strategy we would try to get
move would take the step in the
direction they increase the altitude
as quickly as possible so in
taking the poc that corresponds to a step
which immediately increases us the most
possible our altitude
this algorithm years it is not guaranteed
to find
the global maximum one maximizes one
overall way the overall optima so by
example if the name we are the function
fdn which corresponds to this function
here that go up like this the institute is
that our state simply corresponds to
an integer value n 1 or a real that
determines where are we on
this curve there imagine that we
do not initialize the search at this point here
the clan's algorithm but actually
you will move quietly to this
summit if of the function one observes that
locally
if we look at just lotto of the function
it is indeed a maximum on the other hand
there is another place where we have a
value of the hdr function which is more
big so here it would be the maximum
overall it would have reached 6 instead
like the initials we had provided this
suniula here so this hate value
here actually despite two bing clubs
you'll have to move like that until you
f2m value that would have brought us to this
value so so we found out as no
final this here here other types of
solutions we could get is
for example if we had initialize here
we would have stopped the sentry once
we would have reached the bar their dream of
hate right here who's right at the bar in
made of a kind of trays the plateau
is to be locally a garden
maximum as far as his look of
here or here we come to their lowest
but we could also reach a
plateau that actually is not a maximum
locally ie if we were
arrived at this place if the search is
stopped since we do not have a name right
next to value right next to them
allows to improve the apn function
on the other hand if we had crossed the
plateau are cited allowed to do that one
could have reached that point here and
continue to increase in fact so
locally this point the eye not even a
local maximum but it's a point that
would have stopped the war
still okay so this is one of
properties certain disadvantage we want
of the method he raves goodbye a
example of running the algorithm
imagine that we are the function f of
hate that has the following values ​​being
given all the values ​​of hatred that we
a strange dance here and we'll be there
that our space corresponds to integers
from senegal to 1 up to an equal to 5 is
so here we are interested in what would
the output of the algorithm is what
would have returned if we gave as the
initials n equals 6 and the neighbors
the successor nees would be given in
looking at the value of a hate - hour
and 1,200 and 6 obviously if we find
an equal 1 in this case we will look
not be less if we were to n
equal one would not look at the value
of m more and more that we look at
running the algorithm then at the
first northern iteration is initialized
n attend what would be associated with a
value of f2 so what is two if we
look at the two neighbors 5 and 7
the neighbor that the value f2m prime the
higher these seven so f27 it's equal
at 4 and in this case also actually
f27 is larger than f26 so the
new no current would correspond to a
equal
this next alteration we looked at
the neighbors of 7 namely 8 and 6 think
that if a wood that the value of f
objective function the most objective
highest forgiveness
these eight actually worth f / 2 8
who is 5
this value the 5th largest than fdn
for the non current which is at 4 and so
we would make a transition by assigning the
bare current to l of 8
we will continue then is legal 8 on
would look at the neighbors who are a
premium equals nine or between meygal 7 because
that if it's an equal premium 9 that's
associated with f2 as a bonus
which is the highest at 6 and in addition f2
prints rent a premium is equal to 6 to 9
talk and associates is bigger than
f2m where was born the runner who is 8 so
to be 8 is equal to 5 and so we will do
again a transition from eight to
nine and six in a row until we
arrives at menu twelve where we observe that
for an equal 12 on f2 n equals 10
and in this case also the two neighbors 13
and 11 are associated with values ​​of the
objective function which is lower
ie nine and eight in what if
our algorithm that would be advanced then
will return the crown hate value
which is doubt so we had a return of
hate values ​​that would be a doubt
another example maybe a little bit more
interesting would be the example of the points
d and game one queen's that I have
previously described
so in this case also a node n
would correspond to a configuration of
the chessboard a way configure
to encode a configuration would be to
list the position of each
annuities in each of the columns
so in this case also the first queen
for the first column is at the
position 5 at the fifth rank I have here
it would be 6.7
they fell to 4 5 6 7 6 6 6 so that
it would be the 2nd crown value for
this this board as a function
goal we could use the number
pairs of reindeer
mutually directly or
indirectly so indirectly it wants
say for example take the water here
directly attack that one the attak not
directly because it is blocked by
this rule is here by cons are there
and here the queen here will attack that one
and vice versa it will be against is also
as a pair who knows maybe because
that if indirectly it would be a
example of a poem of optimization of
minimization so we want to decrease the
more possible the number of pairs of
reindeer who is attacking to get
finally the little male who
would correspond to f2 n equals zero so the
better than one can think that none
ream that are attacking and for the
configuration that we see here
in fact we have a value of f which
corresponds to 17 I will not do the math
explicitly but could do it there
to check and the successors we
could define that would be the whole
chessboard configurations
would correspond to take a single queen
in a row in a column sorry
and move it to the same symposium
for example we could take it is 36
and then moved it here or here or here and if
you are the figure that is illustrated in
this image here makes it worth f2
end if we took the queen of the column
and I was moving this rule to aso
this new box there so 14 it wants
to say that if I took a failure whose
configuration would be the same for all
the reindeer waves except this one which
would be moved here we would have a value
from fdn wayne primeau
it would be a neighbor who would correspond to
the same way if I took this train there
and that it was rather that train that I
move and that I brought it here on
would have a function value
goal of 12
because if we notice that the best
we can do is reach our
neighbors that would correspond to f function
goal of 12
Moreover, we have several
several breaks that correspond to
move the queen from that column there and
which corresponds to a function
of goals of 12 in this case also he
that we would have a good equality
could do is take as not
Preferred choice
a priori we do not take anything
choosing them randomly
now here is the description that
I come to give a description of
comment on what we would do
gatehouse but a chronicle to solve
the problem of Le Havre we could
reach risks too rather than
local maxim had a maximum
local we would have a local minimum
we have succeeded that corresponds to a draw
and frankly this configuration there and
whose objective value would be a
victims in a single pair in that
six to tax it's very slow here these
prelates and I hope the exercise but
in fact if we move any
queen in his column did we go
necessarily increase or get
an objective function equal to 1
so it will not be possible from
this configuration the place sound a
only queen in his water column
maybe to get a better value
and in this case if the rumor tells so
we have reached the equivalent of a minimum
local since by doing a single
change to a neighbor one can
only worsen the objective function